envie de s'arrêter elle dit qu'elle
s'arrête je la rappelle finalement elle
s'arrête pas elle dit qu'elle sa nièce
avec elle et pour terminer là elle
essaie de nous semer parce que en fait
elle voulait me donner rendez-vous à
Grigny pour me faire un guet-apens
ferme
la porte
c'est une blague t'inquiète t'inquiète
voilà t'inquiète pas
mais ouais regardez la bouffonne comment
elle est repartie regardez comment elle
est repartie cette bouffonne je filme je
filme je filme wesh regarde vas-y c'est
une malade et la vie de ma mère alors
Anthony martial qu'un joueur en plus que
je kiffe
des courses poursuites dans un premier
temps il est en couple avec Samantha
jacliné ils sont restés 3 ans ensemble
ils ont une fille pétone
en 2016 ce sont séparés après plusieurs
tromperie de la part du joueur de foot
et après ça séparation avec Samantha le
joueur s'est mis en couple avec
l'ex-candidate de télé-réalité Mélanie
Da Cruz ils sont restés 5 ans en couple
ils ont un enfant ensemble Peyton
il s'appelle Swan
[Applaudissements]
ils se sont mariés en 2020 ils ont
annoncé leur séparation entre le 31 mars
2022 ensuite Anthony martial et tu es en
couple avec une jeune fille qui
s'appelle Stone je savais pas qui
c'était ils sont ensemble depuis donc le
1er avril 2023 2022 2022 première avril
dominante 2 ils ont eu un enfant qui
s'appelle Swan Peyton
[Rires]
donc samantha est persuadée qu'Anthony
l'a quitté pour Mélanie donc forcément
elle est vénère c'est ça oui et même
qu'ils avaient une relation avant leur
séparation officielle c'est pour ça
qu'elle se déteste depuis le début et
que sur les réseaux depuis des années
elle s'insulte mais là elle se cherche
et là elles se sont trouvées ça a passé
un statut supérieur
pour dire que c'était pas bien on va
ouvrir mais qu'est-ce que oui non mais
moi je trouve que c'est catastrophique
pardon mais d'abord ce sont deux jeunes
femmes deux adultes elles sont maires
donc et elles ont des enfants qui sont
donc
des enfants qui sont demi-frères et
demi-sœurs donc quelle image elles vont
renvoyer quel cercle familial ça va
faire quand ses enfants vont se
retrouver ensemble non c'est ta mère
dans ta mère dans ta mère alors que
elles ont été en commun alors que ses
enfants ont un père en commun je trouve
ça terrible et pour elle et pour leurs
enfants et voilà il y a et pour
l'exemple qu'elle donne parce que
des gros compte apparemment de gens qui
les femmes
c'est pas grave
elle a tenu à signaler que le
comportement des deux femmes faisaient
des excès de vitesse il aurait pu son
permis
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ce qui s'est passé c'est absolument pas
un exemplacement à suivre je le sais et
autre chose
ça c'est important deux femmes qui
communiquent elles seront toujours plus
fortes que deux femmes qui se divisent
je sais pourquoi je dis ça ce qui sont
là depuis le départ comprendront la
communication c'est 10 fois mieux que la
division parce que ça profite à certains
c'est bien qu'elle est fait cette vidéo
et la violence la moche la violence
la violence c'est pas bien ne résout pas
la violence par la violence moi ça me
rappelle une histoire ah oui je vous
explique l'histoire que j'ai fait je
vous raconter une histoire je peux dire
mon truc juste avant allez-y alors
effectivement il y a plus intéressant
que ce que je dis
on a vu des marques sur le visage de
Mélanie mais elles ont conclu toutes les
deux de ne pas dire la conclusion de
cette baston en disant on va pas dire
qui a gagné voilà elles sont là les
images on va pas dire qu'il y a gagné on
va pas dire qu'il a perdu juste elle se
sont entendues à la fin elles ont une
discussion et maintenant notre on
entendra plus parler d'elle elles se
sont mises elles se sont accordées
ensemble et il y aura plutôt
alors moi j'ai fait un truc la semaine
dernière qui était incroyable j'ai un
ami en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
son fils c'est embrouillé avec un petit
de l'école
et il a appelé le petit de l'école pour
dire oui truc il faut arrêter de vous de
vous engueuler tout ça parce qu'en plus
vous étiez potes avant tout ça etc etc
et donc pendant le déjeuner ils nous
racontent
qu'est-ce que je fais médiateur
j'appelle le gars mon pote je vais
appeler par un pote à moi et il se fait
passer pour le père du petit qu'il a
appelé
et là ça démarre ouais tu es où là tout
de suite là mais non mais oui vous êtes
qui je suis le papa de Théo là ouais
c'est toi qui a appelé mon fils non mais
je l'ai appelé parce que pour moi
tu vas prendre ta gif je vais venir tout
de suite chez toi
et là il a eu cette phrase magique on ne
résout pas la violence par la violence
il est bien
j'ai pris des Vans je fais des quand
même le roi des bouffons
voilà il a rappelé 15 fois c'était
génial voilà c'était génial et depuis
les deux enfants voilà ce sont Rabbi
bossés voyez pas comme quoi tu peux
partir d'une blague mais en vérité c'est
vrai vous avez vu comment elles sont
mieux là les deux c'est bien l'exemple à
la fin c'est bien et bravo Kelly mais
vous y croyez vraiment à leur journée